It was an invention that would change the world of photography.
Kodak patented the digital camera in 1978.
While the invention was a technological innovation,...
...it also marked the beginning of Kodak's demise.
By the end of the 1980s,...
...digital imaging was squeezing Kodak's profit margins in the consumer space.
It was a revolving door in the C-Suite.
CEO Colby Chandler and his successor Kay Whitmore had a big problem:
...transitioning from the 70 to 80% margins of photo film sales,...
...to the 3 to 4% margins of consumer electronics.
In 2005, Kodak brought in CEO Antonio Perez.
He saw the future in consumer printers.
Perez, who'd come from Hewlett-Packard, couldn't change the culture of Kodak,...
...and had difficulties dealing with legacy Kodak leadership.
After decades of mismanagement and colossal growth in digital photography,...
...Kodak filed for bankruptcy on January 19th, 2012.